إنها موهوبة جدًا وذكية جدًا
وسريعة جدًا وأعتقد أنها ستحظى
باحترام جميع دونالد ترامب وهو ينتقد
كريس كريستي جنبًا إلى جنب مع ناشر
أكبر صحيفة في نيو هامبشاير ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على حضوركم
ومرحبًا بكم في وزارة الخارجية. إنه
لشرف حقيقي أن  كونوا هنا مع
جميعكم الذين تخدمون في وزارة الخارجية ،
كان هناك الكثير من
ضباط الخدمة الخارجية وموظفي الخدمة المدنية المذهلين
، كان من الرائع أن يكون لدينا حوالي خمس
دقائق معًا
، أعرف أن الكثير من المؤسسات الإعلامية ترغب
في الاستمرار في العودة إلى هذه
الإدارة  لقد كان قاسيًا على روسيا
غدًا في ذكرى
الغزو في يوم النصر ، من الواضح أن لدينا تاريخًا طويلاً للغاية
مع حكومة
ألمانيا ولدينا علاقة قوية
مع الحكومة
فيما يتعلق بما نبحث عنه عادةً في
سيرتها الذاتية للأمم المتحدة  ضعيفة للغاية ،
تجربتنا في الدبلوماسية
غير موجودة كما يمكنني أن أقول لكم
[موسيقى]
لك